[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle rien et mon acolyte
là c'est andres aux méandres au
s'appelle en réalité antoine et antoine
il communique en faisant des bruits
étranges et il en fait beaucoup
[Musique]
alors comme ça ça n'a pas trop de sens
mais en les articulant les uns avec les
autres
ça peut en prendre ce qui fait la sphère
de la musique avec sa bouche c'est une
discipline hip hop qui s'appelle le
beatbox alors on parle souvent des
quatre éléments du hip hop on a le rap
le graphe de deejaying et la danse et
puis on a le beatbox le cinquième
élément
un peu moins connus que les autres à la
base le beatbox c'est une aide rythmique
pour que les rappeurs de rue puisse
entraîner et affûter leurs lyrics et
puis petit à petit le beatbox et
émancipée du rappeur il a évolué et est
devenu un art à part entière
un des premiers grands beatboxer à
mettre le beatbox sur le devant de la
scène
sablé d'oubli frêche ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que chaque beatboxer à son
identité vocale
doogie sa particularité c'est de faire
beaucoup de clics et puis quelques
années après est apparue une des grandes
légendes du beatbox
il s'est fait appeler de god for a dream
nourrissent aussi connu sous le nom de
razel
[Musique]
merci antoine et puis ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que à partir des années 2000 et
encore plus après 2010 il ya énormément
de beat boxer qui ont qu'ils ont émergé
et andro en fait partie
[Musique]
ouais moi aussi j'ai voulu faire ça
c'est pas vraiment facile la première
fois que j'ai découvert le beatbox
c'était en 2003 je devais avoir à peu
près 15 ans ça m'a tout de suite
beaucoup intéressé parce que c'était une
façon très particulière personnel est
étonnante de faire de la musique
alors j'ai essayé à l'époque il n'y
avait pas beaucoup d'autres choix que de
trouver des vidéos de beat boxer sur
internet et d'essayer de reproduire leur
performance mais c'est pas vraiment
facile parce qu'en fait on peut pas voir
ce que fait le beatboxer pour produire
tous ces sons mais j'ai eu de la chance
parce que au milieu des années 2000
c'est justement le moment où sont
apparus les premiers tutoriel sur
youtube dans ces courtes vidéos un
beatboxer vous montre quel organe
mobilisés et comment utiliser l'air pour
produire un son après il ya plus qu'à
s'entraîner ça m'a permis de débuter et
de faire des rythmiques simple mais
quand j'ai voulu créer mes propres
rythmique j'étais confronté un deuxième
problème le tutoriel c'est bien pour
recopier la rythmique de quelqu'un
d'autre
mais quand on veut créer quelque chose
de nouveau se pose le problème de la
mémorisation et ce problème de
mémorisation j étais moi-même pour vous
confronter passer une journée entière à
travailler sur une rythmique à la fin de
la journée commençait à la tenir à la
mémoriser aller me coucher et en me
levant le lendemain impossible de m'en
rappeler
et ça c'est très frustrant ah oui
antoine parle aussi
et moi aussi j'ai souvent été confronté
à ce problème
et un matin frustré de pas me rappeler
ce que j'avais fait la veille
je me suis dit qu'il fallait trouver une
solution alors je me suis retourné vers
internet encore une fois et j'ai cherché
à voir s'il n'y avait pas des systèmes
qui permettait d'écrire et son du
beatbox écrire ça permet de laisser une
trace et donc ne pas oublier mais ça
permet aussi plein d'autres choses comme
par exemple retravailler un premier jet
ou même le partager à quelqu'un lorsque
la création et abouti en cherchant je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait des
beatboxers qui avait essayé de mettre en
place des systèmes d'écriture le plus
connu c'était un système assez simple
qui utilisaient les lettres de
l'alphabet le p pour un système
il permet d'apprendre les bases
d'ailleurs on l'appelle le pt cas pour
ça mais le problème c'est qu'ils
éviteraient limité parce que les deux
boxeurs crée souvent de nouveaux sont
donc des vues qu'on veut commencer à
pouvoir écrire un bon ben voilà c'est
tout petit plusieurs en cherchant encore
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
chercheur sonore du nom de dan ce
taureau qui avait utilisé les signes de
l'alphabet phonétique internationale
pour coder les sons du beatbox et ce
système là il est nettement plus complet
mais il est aussi beaucoup plus complexe
parce qu'il contient plus de 140 signes
et à la base il n'a pas été créé pour
permettre d'écrire de la rythmique je me
suis quand même essayé et j'ai vite
arrêté puisque ans j'ai eu du mal à
déchiffrer des choses que j'avais
moi-même écrite et en cherchant encore
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
des beat boxer qu'avait créé leur propre
système
pas forcément pour le donner aux autres
mais pour les aider eux à créer et dans
ses systèmes certains utilisent des
signes abstraits comme des cercles des
cars et des croix il y en a encore
d'autres qui ont détourné des systèmes
de rythmiques de batterie
mais au final il n'y a aucun de ces
systèmes qui a su s'imposer comme le
langage universel du beatbox créé le
langage universel du beatbox
c'est notre projet c'est un projet que
j'ai initiées en tant que projet de fin
d'études
j'étais dans une école de design
graphique et typographie pour réussir à
créer ce langage
j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches et j'ai
écrit un mémoire sur cette thématique
l'écriture du beatbox j'ai analysé tous
les systèmes d'écriture de la langue et
de la musique pour essayer de comprendre
leur fonctionnement de déterminer leurs
points forts mais aussi leurs limites
ce que j'ai compris c'est qu'un bon
système
c'est pas un système qui veut tout faire
à la fois c'est un système qui
s'articule autour des points les plus
importants d'une discipline pour lui
permettre d'exprimer tout son potentiel
et d'évoluer à travers le temps et pour
le beatbox le plus important c'est que
ce système il soit facile pour qu'ils
puissent être a pris facilement par
d'autres faut aussi qu'il soit complet
pour pouvoir répertorier tous les
différents sons qu'on a il faut aussi
qu'ils soient évolutifs pour permettre
de retranscrire les différents sons
qu'on va y ajouter et enfin faut qu'il
soit réfléchie pour permettre la
transmission de connaissances
parce que la transmission de
connaissances c'est une des choses les
plus importantes pour l'évolution de
notre discipline
ce système je l' ai mis au point grâce à
de nombreuses collaborations avec des
designers des typographes des linguistes
des musiciens et puis je les présente et
pour mon diplôme
il a été bien accueilli j'ai eu les
félicitations du jury et j'ai réussi
adecco a dégoté des publications dans
des magazines d'art et de design
mais le moment où l'histoire devient
vraiment intéressante c'est que quelques
jours après mon diplôme je suis retourné
voir certaines des personnes qui
m'avaient aidé tout au long du chemin
notamment deux de mes professeurs
laurent et olivier quand un studio de
design à paris
quand je leur ai dit que je passais ils
étaient contents de voir le résultat de
mon travail et ils m'ont dit ça tombe
bien on a un beatboxer qui travaillent
dans les bureaux d'à côté il viendra
écouté ta présentation alors j'y suis
allé c'était la première fois que
j'allais montrer mon travail fini à un
beatboxer et quand je suis arrivé je me
suis rendu compte que ce beat boxer bas
c'était andro champion de france en
titre en duo de beatbox
ça m'a mis un peu la pression mais j'ai
pris mon courage à deux mains et ce
projet
je lui ai présenté comme lui il va vous
le présentez aujourd'hui vocal gramat
ticks c'est un système qui est fondé sur
des études politiques articulatoires la
phonétique articulatoires c'est la
science qui décrit la production des
sons grâce à deux informations
principales
la première c'est quelle partie de la
bouche sont mobilisés la deuxième c'est
comment est-ce qu'on va utiliser l'air
pour produire ce sont et nous notre
système il fonctionne grâce à deux
catégories de signes qui vont
répertorier ces deux informations
la première c'est les signes qui
indiquent quelles parties de la bouche
est mobilisé ici on a par exemple les
deux lèvres
là c'est la pointe de la langue contre
l'avant du palais est ici c'est la
racine de la longue pause et contre
l'arrière du palais la deuxième
catégorie de signes c'est les psy qui
décrivent qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
l'air
comme par exemple la croix qui va
désigner un insigne explosif l'explosif
c'est à dire qu'on retient l'air et
qu'on le relâche de manière explosive ou
encore la vague qui signifie frais katif
c'est à dire qu'il va y avoir peu
d'espacé entre deux organes de la bouche
et que le passage de l'air va créer une
friction
mais pour qu'il y ait un rendu sonore
il faut qu on combine ces deux éléments
un peu comme des briques ici on retrouve
le symbole des lèvres ainsi que le
symbole de l'explosif ce qui va donner
le ensuite ici ce qu'on peut voir aussi
cecab rien à donner une taille
différente à ces deux éléments pour
qu'on puisse les différencier facilement
ensuite ici on va retrouver la racine de
la langue posé contre l'arrière du
palais avec la significative ce qui va
donner le et souvent les beat boxer vont
avoir besoin de combiner deux techniques
vocales ou plus pour créer un seul sens
par exemple ici on va réutiliser le et
le pour faire le bien
et à partir de ça on va pouvoir a créé
des rythmiques et adrien vous avez pas
dit mme boxer aussi ça c'est ce que j'ai
présenté antoine lors de notre première
rencontre et ça m'a tout de suite
beaucoup plus puisque ça répond à des
problématiques que j'avais en tant que
boxeur et ça m'a permis aussi d'avoir
une réflexion sur la façon de pratiquer
ajouter de la théorie et du coup j'ai
tout de suite voulu rejoindre le projet
et grâce à antoine on a pu identifier
écrire et enregistrer sans techniques de
beatbox et ça c'est super sauf il ya
encore une question qui se posait
c'était comment est ce qu'on allait
faire pour transmettre ce système au
beat boxer et aux gens qui voudraient
apprendre la beatbox et pour ça antoine
et moi on est en train de développer une
application qui permettra à n'importe
qui de découvrir d'apprendre et de créer
ce soir on va vous en présenter une
partie le composent heures de signes
avec cet outil le beatboxer en herbe va
pouvoir se familiariser avec le système
d'écriture et découvrir des nouvelles
techniques vocales
ici on a des informations sur les
différents sens qui nous sont proposés
en les sélectionnant on peut les
combinés et avoir un rendu sonore est
aussi avoir des informations sur la
manière dont on peut créer sont
aujourd'hui on a 100 techniques vocales
ont enregistré c'est tout seul que je
sais faire mais il y en a beaucoup
beaucoup plus certaine que je sais
absolument pas faire et que d'autres
beatboxer safer d'autres qui n'ont
jamais été répertorié encore donc si
vous vous savez faire cessons là parce
qu'on vous propose c'est de nous
l'envoyer pour qu'on puisse ajouter de
la bibliothèque avec cette
fonctionnement notre but c'est que vous
ou n'importe quel beatboxer où qu'ils
soient dans le monde puisse y ait
participé à l'agrandissement notre
bibliothèque universelle du beatbox et
ainsi participer à l'évolution de la
discipline
pour la petite histoire j'ai utilisé ce
système est l'application avec une des
mes jeunes élèves qui j'apprends le
beatbox elle s'appelle juliette elle a
10 ans et je lui ai montré dans ses
systèmes et au bout de dix minutes
elle avait compris comment ça
fonctionnait donc j'ai pour la suite de
la séance je lui ai appris quelques
signes ainsi que le rendu sonore
correspondant à ces différents signé à
la fin de la séance
elle arrivait à écrire une rythmique
simple avec les signes que je l'avais
appris j'ai tout de suite appelé adrien
pour le dire que
ça donnait quelque chose de quand même
très concluants pour une séance et là où
ça m'a beaucoup surpris c'est à la
séance suivante quand je suis retourné
la voir et qu'elle m'a montré qu'elle
avait réussi à écrire d'autres consignes
d'autres sont à partir de signes que je
l'avais montré juste en les combinant
comme je l'avais expliqué mais tout seul
sans moi et là on était vraiment bluffé
on vous remercie pour votre écoute et on
vous laisse avec un petit freestyle
[Musique]
[Rires]
merci merci merci beaucoup